As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh. How are you guys doing? I'm
here somewhere in Eastern Europe, but
I've got something to say cuz we just
watched the the fight, the Khamzat fight
with Sean Strickland. A lot of people
are speaking about it, and some people
are even saying this is a fixed fight.
But cuz you're seeing Khamzat, you know,
acting in uncharacteristic manner, you
know, in the second round in particular
where he kind of pulled guard
essentially. He went down on after
trying a takedown, a double leg
takedown. He went down on his back.
People are saying this is very
uncharacteristic. Was it Trump that came
in and basically gave him an ultimatum
that if he doesn't give this to
Strickland, who is a very pro-Trump
individual, that
you know, that he's going to do such and
such to him. I don't think any of that
happened. I think what really happened
was this is that Strickland, for all of
his nonsense, and we find him a
despicable individual, a racist
individual, an unacceptable individual,
but for all of his nonsense, is a very
formidable and experienced opponent.
Okay, remember, he's had 37 professional
MMA fights. He's been here 37 times
before. Compare him with Khamzat
Chimaev, who's had 15 professional MMA
fights and only one amateur MMA fight.
There's a essentially double the amount
of experience. And he's very good, and
we've said this before. And I was having
a conversation with Firas Zahabi,
which you can see on Muhammad Hijab
Encounters channel, which you can check
out. It's a new channel that we put up.
You can see that this was always a
concern that he's, you know, he can keep
getting up and keep frustrating Khamzat.
And everyone knows about who does MMA
that the the the takedowns in the MMA
game and the grappling exchanges are the
most energy-consuming aspect of MMA. And
that's the problem. That's the trade-off
that a lot of these kind of
wrestling-based MMA fighters have to
make. And that's why a lot of them, you
you for example, Cejudo, etc.
Or even Yoel Romero as an example,
right? These guys, although they're
they're Olympic-level MMA fight
wrestlers, they'll come into the the
octagon and actually primarily strike.
I've got Gaethje is another example of
that, and there's many other examples of
people who are wrestlers who primarily
strike. And the only reasonable excuse I
can think for that is that they know
their opponent knows that they know how
to wrestle, and so they can do the
defensive wrestling, and they don't want
to expend that much energy in a 5-minute
round over five rounds, and that's 25
minutes wrestling.
So, that's
it's understandable that in the first
round, what happened was he overextended
himself. He's he squeezed a lot on
Strickland. He had an adrenaline dump.
There was so much you know expectation
on him, and what happened is that he
sort of collapsed, and then he had to
regain composure. That to me makes more
sense than to say that it was fixed or
that Trump had a you know hand to play
in this matter or something like this.
Even though I would love to be able to
you know to espouse this conspiracy
theory myself, but the characteristic
signs of a fixed fight were not there in
this. That's the first point I want to
make. The second point is this. Look,
um Khamzat Chimaev is a great fighter.
He's a great wrestler. He's a great uh
in many ways ambassador, you know, for
the of Islam, for the for the for the
dignity and for the strength of Islam,
okay? Yes, he he does things which are
unbecoming and un-integrity. Sometimes
it's like all of us do, right? And uh to
be honest with you,
the main thing is that with Sean
Strickland, he called Sean Strickland
called Khamzat's mother a He
mentioned things about Chechnya. He
mentioned things about Islam. Actually,
theologically, I have to say this, it's
not acceptable to be nice to him, okay?
It's actually not acceptable to be nice
to him from an Islamic perspective. Why?
Because even if he apologizes for it
afterwards or he excuses it by saying
you know it's just business and I'm
selling a fight, and you know, we don't
forgive you, Sean Strickland, for that,
I'm afraid, because you can't go that
far and say well it's excused. No other
community will accept it. We don't
accept it, yeah? So, I don't like the
fact that he was sort of
overcompensating. However, I give
concession to Khamzat. The reason why is
because
when you're in that state before and
after a fight,
your adrenaline spikes, your dopamine
spikes, your neurotransmitters, they
fluctuate in such a way
uh that most people would not
understand. It's akin to if not more
severe than intoxication. Way more
way severe than intoxication. The highs,
the lows, the the feelings that you get
from it. So, if he at that moment
decided to be sportsmanlike,
it's not like he knew the theological
intricacies of what was allowed and
permissible and or what's not allowed
and impermissible. Some people are
saying, "Well, if that was Khabib, he
would have done such and such. If that
was um Islam Makhachev, he wouldn't
have." But, this compa- this constant
comparison between, you know, strong
Islamic figures and sports people and
stuff like that is actually what's
destroying the ummah. Okay, we need to
show support to people. We need to give
advice, constructive advice, but should
support. The fact is this,
Khamzat, Khabib, and Islam Makhachev,
whether we like it or not, have done
more for the case of promoting Islam
than a lot of da'wah have, okay? If not
all of them all the da'wah. Because the
fact is this,
they are promoting Islam in a way that
that they're showing that it's
uh it's okay. So, you can you can be a
Muslim, you can be a sportsman, you you
can be relatable, you can be strong, you
can These are These are things that
we're doing. And there's no there's no
ready replacements for these guys, you
know?
So, you you want to throw them away like
a lot of Muslim people are attacking
Khamzat Chimaev and saying, "He should
have done this and he should have done
that and we should throw him away."
With all due respect, like are you going
to replace him? Get into the octagon
yourself. Could you have done a better
job? Do you know about the intricacies
of this? It yani, no. So, what we need
to do with with our sports people who
are not ashamed, okay, of the Islamic
symbols in Islam, then we should
actually show them, you know, respect
and we should show them backing. We
should back them. And everyone will
lose. Everyone Every human being Allah
says that in the Quran, "We'll take a
day and then we'll have a day with us."
And these are the days that we will
alternate between the people. The
Sahabah had moments where they weren't
victorious, essentially Uhud. That was a
moment where they weren't victorious,
okay?
Um but, what makes it worse, and the
Quran says, is when we differ after
that. With for that and is after that
where for that shall we have a day with
you to do with differ because then you
will fail and you're moral you're you
become demoralized. Okay. So, that's the
first lesson that we need to We're not
always going to win, but we need to know
how to to balance it out.
We need to know how to show support to
our guys. Number one. And number two is
that you're not going to find a
replacement for these guys are able to
do it. We can constructively criticize
what they're doing, but throwing them
away essentially saying oh, they're
finished like I've seen it online and
stuff like that. It's actually
disgusting to be honest. And as I said,
he he he lost a split decision, an
arguable split decision. As I said, the
first round he definitely won. The
second round Strickland won. The other
three rounds frankly can make a very
strong case that Hamzat won the fight,
right? You can make the strong case that
it was because it was American judges
and he was at home and all these kind of
things that he won the fight. He had
more, you know, dominance across the on
the fence. He he he put he took him down
a couple of times. Even his striking
wasn't that bad. He landed some
significant strikes with the right hand.
Strickland jabbed
a lot and he was doing the defensive
defensive strikes. So, you can make an
argument. I'm not a judge. I'm not here
to make these arguments.
I can't speak about that. But what I can
say is it wasn't that bad of a loss. He
didn't even get knocked out or submitted
or finished or anything like that. So,
it wasn't that kind of a bad of a loss.
It was a split decision loss. One of the
three judges considered Hamzat to be
victorious
in that.
Another thing I'll say is this. Look, as
Muslims we also have to understand that
good and bad things are going to happen
to us in our life. Okay? And this is for
Hamzat as well. I've met him. Hamzat
I've wrestled with him as people know.
We raised a lot of money together in
that wrestling match. I I think a
million pounds actually. Alhamdulilah.
And he's a brilliant wrestler. He's an
excellent athlete and and a good person.
Very humble by the way. People don't
know Hamzat's actually humble. All
right? He This is I'm not going to say
performative, but he does this with
certain things. But when you see him in
the flesh, he's a very humble guy, man.
You sit with him. He actually stood up
when the Sheikh came in. He has these
mannerisms. Yeah, he's a good guy.
But everybody needs to understand that
there's going to be good moments and bad
moments. And the Prophet Muhammad
told us this in the most beautiful
Hadith, my favorite Hadith actually.
Which is the following.
Wonderful is the affair of the believer
in
that all of his affair is good.
If he if good things happen to him, he's
thankful. When
bad things happen to him, he's patient
and he's thankful as well. So, we
we don't have this situation where we
feel like bad things are going to happen
to us. We've got to always look at the
optimistic side. Our religion is a
religion of optimism, okay?
This is the best lesson that you can For
Hamza it's actually one of the best
lessons. He was pushed to the limit.
He was tested by a more experienced
opponent.
He's going to become a better man after
that. Okay. And even those who like
people compare him with Khabib and
people compare